[Music]
well we begin with breaking news a
strong
earthquake in the aegean sea has shaken
turkey and greece
rescuers are searching for survivors
after the magnitude seven quake caused a
building
to collapse there is no information at
this time
on casualties let's uh across to
istanbul now where we can speak with
cinema kosiolu
at cinema this earthquake we understand
struck just 60 minutes ago or so
what information do you have for us at
this time
according to the official information we
have according to
interior ministry let me say they have
reports of
six buildings that have collapsed after
this earthquake and
according to izmir's mayor municipal
mayor
they have received the reports of 20
buildings that have collapsed so
far we don't have uh we is so actually
the rescue and search teams are
dispatched to the area that's why we
will be able to learn more accurate
information as soon as they reach to er
they reach the ground but what we have
heard from the officials is that they
have also asked for
extra vehicles and extra personnel who
that would be that would help for the
search and rescue teams
and according to the official
information so far
three districts have been heavily
impacted by this earthquake
by iraq abuja and bornowa and
if we're born of a district an official
said that
since it's an agricultural area and it's
a low land there is not
high damage but what we see on the
pictures is that it is that damage seems
to be high
and there are fumes uh because of the
buildings collapsing because of the
concrete and
we we see those people who are trying to
get to the area and also
turkey's disaster management agency made
an announcement
saying that people shouldn't flock to
the areas because they are causing
traffic jam
that's why it is getting more difficult
to reach to the areas this is the
situation on the ground and
what we have what we have so what we
have so far
as an information about the earthquake
it was
16.5 14.5 kilometers
deep under the ground so it was a heavy
shake for izmir despite this western
coastal city
is used to some earthquake because for
uh for the last one year turkey's
western coast has
has been witnessing earthquakes very
frequently
the magnitudes were always between 3.3
up to 4.5 izmir mula those western
cities which are across greece
have been witnessing those earthquakes
but this was heavy this was a big one
and now there is a damage and we know
that
surrounding cities nearby cities also
felt the earthquake and
there are reports of some small damages
like tracks on the buildings in the
nearby cities as well and
some people even in istanbul were able
to feel the
strength of this earthquake and well
quite
as you mentioned there uh this is an
area which is used
to seismic activity the fact that
so many buildings have been reduced to
rubble and we're showing our viewers uh
pictures now
of the plumes of smoke coming up from
the city of izmir suggesting
several buildings have come down in that
it gives a sense of just how strong
this particular earthquake has been now
as you
said there's sin and we we still have no
information on how many casualties how
many people have been trapped
under the rubble of these buildings but
set the scene for us uh describe if you
will
what kind of city is mira is how large
is
it is this in an area that sees
for example lots of visitors tourism
because
it is a coastal city on the aegean sea
exactly so far according to the izmir
governor the city governor
there are no reports of women that but
as you said we don't know how many
people
are trapped under those rubles and the
initial report suggests that according
to interior ministry
they have reports of six buildings that
have collapsed but
according to izmir municipality the
mayor announced that they have reports
of
20 buildings collapsed in izmir
it's it's one of the largest cities of
turkey hala and
for both domestic and foreign tourists
it's a very attractive area
it's a historical city by the asian
coast across
greece and also it is it is the point of
this
it's a destination for the migrants who
are trying to illegally cross from
turkey to europe uh through the agency
most of the times they use some specific
uh districts like iowa and other places
of izmir it took uh to to hire boats
those
uh unsafe boats to cross agency
get to greece and then to europe this is
the illegal migration
route but when you come to the
urbanization of the city
the city center the downtown is highly
uh
highly cons there are very high
buildings it's
mostly concrete it's a crowded city
because the city that it does not only
serve by a serve with
tourism but also with industry and other
services sectors
in these suburbs and where or when you
go outside the city
the density of the buildings are lower
and the height of the buildings are
lower but the city center
that we mostly see on the pictures right
now are highly
populated and too many there are too
many buildings over there which
increases the
risk of human loss
as these buildings collapse and as i
said so far
we have no reports of casualties but
seeing that people flocking to the area
they are looking for their relatives or
loved ones
uh under these rubble salah absolutely
and the pictures that we're showing
our viewers right now we do see uh
crowds of people flocking out onto the
street this usually happens
when there is an earthquake because it's
safer to get out
of a uh out of a building um
we are showing our viewers also pictures
of people who are clambering
over the uh the collapsed buildings and
trying to move
rubble with their bare hands you
mentioned earlier cinnamon that there
have been
certainly contrasting uh data being
given by different
seismic organizations um but certainly
the u.s uh
geological uh survey uh saying this is a
7.0
magnitude quake just to put this into
context
um back in 1999 there was a 7.4
magnitude quake in that area
an earthquake that was so strong it
killed some 17 000
people a thousand of whom were in
istanbul so
these sorts of earthquakes they will
carry
some kind of toll sim were there any
tremors felt
in istanbul where you're reporting from
well hello istanbul is also another
risky city inside
in turkey that is facing a risk of a
very
strong earthquake that's why the
organizations the civil institutions are
calling for
urban transformation especially to
backup support the structure of those
old buildings that have been damaged or
that are
that are potentially going to be damaged
or
demolish and build new ones
and it's in istanbul or we are hearing
that some people were able to feel the
strength of this
earthquake but it depends on where you
are because istanbul is a very large
city
and also it depends on the ground uh the
ground that you are staying on because
some parts of istanbul are more
sensitive
when it comes to feeling the earthquakes
coming from the asian sea
and uh so far we know that it has been
felt in the nearby
cities around uh izmir and in those
cities the officials have reported that
there are some small damages in the
buildings like some cracks
but in istanbul as i said so far it is
just some reports that people
felt the strength of the earthquake but
istanbul that
that has suffered a huge earthquake
since 2019-99
people are kind of ready for such an
earthquake
a big earthquake people are always in
panic i remember
people used to live with some
backpacks some support bags in their
corridors or inside their cars
in case an earthquake would happen and
they would they would in
they would need to run immediately
from their houses so today it is going
to be the same scenario for
izmir because with this very strong
magnitude earthquake people will not be
able to get in their houses
because the the the size of the damage